sans déconner alors le train c'est
énorme mais le train il y a deux tanasse
dans le train alors je vous le dis c'est
bien parce que c'est bien que tu en
parles moi je prends jamais le train
parce que je vais vous dire il y a un
bain qui me casse les noisettes pas du
tout pas du tout non les mecs non
taisez-vous s'il vous plaît une audit
rien vous ne savez pas c'est il y a des
vous avez des trous là comme ça il y a
des bouches derrière
quoi qu'il arrive tu fais un trajet en
train de plus d'une heure et demie tu as
une bronchite à l'arrivée c'est un truc
de ouf il y a de l'air mon frère mais
c'est pas de l'air mon frère c'est un
truc toi tu es comme un tu veux Midor
frère est adoles ici la vitre elle est
froide mon frère tu te réveilles mon
frère tu as l'impression d'avoir été
chez Picardie il faut mettre le menton
et après il y a un gars parce que
maintenant il te disent maintenant il y
a la voiture restaurant la voiture bar
et là ils font une annonce tu vois
maintenant la musique ils te dis la
voiture barre est ouvert si vous voulez
des sandwichs triangles à 23 euros
les M&M's à 15 euros
ou encore notre magnifique risotto à 72
heures venez nous rejoindre en voiture
numéro 8 frère sur la tête de ma mère
faire quand le gars il arrive il arrive
frère pour te faire payer Baba dans le
train tu as pris deux mlms et une
tartiflette merde qu'on a pour 100
balles
c'est un truc de ouf
le gars il fait chauffer au micro tu le
vois parce qu'il le sort devant moi le
risotto frère il est comme à plus hein
tu mets ton doigt dedans ça y est tu as
déjà mangé c'est fini c'est Koh-Lanta
là-bas de grain de riz qui se baladent
entre trois gars non mais donc ouais il
le met au micro-ondes faire avec le sort
frère tu es comment ou déjà parce que
déjà il y a une queue et de que mon
frère quand il te donne ton riz tu as
l'impression mon frère que tu as gagné
au loto
les gars sortent du wagon
et si tu as rien à voir non les autos on
a plus on a plus une russe par contre
des pâtes aux champignons
à 72 euros
donc pour lever les champignons c'est à
50 balles c'est un truc de ouf
après ah ouais après après
oui non c'est pas ça c'est que d'abord
je voulais gagner de l'argent pour payer
mes études
et économique si on s'économique et
sociales le droit
[Rires]
et après huissier après huissier ah
ouais là c'était une sacrée expérience
chez les gens c'était très dur c'est
pour ça que j'ai arrêté c'est la
première fois que j'ai découvert ce que
c'était lexomil voyez tellement
tellement j'étais triste de devoir
d'abord aller rentrer dans l'intimité
des gens vous devez connaître tous leurs
revenus tous leurs machins
l'indiscrétion totale
[Rires]
non c'est vrai
non j'étais très malheureux de faire ça
les petits boulots
la première à droite c'est juste à côté
des BD le mec et vous mettez un crayon
moi je baie non ça c'est un deux billes
on était collé à un lycée donc il y
avait forcément les papeteries sans
déconner normalement elle est au lieu de
la classe ils allaient acheter leur
fournitures en papeterie quand le gars
il allait chez plein ciel pour aller
acheter ces trucs en papeterie frère le
papier canson mon frère il est à 40
balles frère vrai sur la vie de ma mère
quand tu demandais tu avais pas ton
papier canson à l'école quand t'as pas
ton papier canson tu le demandes à un
gars le gars il a l'impression de te
donner son colis quand il te donne la
feuille de papier canson il y a un côté
Slee c'est un côté à grain derrière et
là il te la donne la feuille elle est
lourde
[Rires]
c'est un truc de ouf moi je me rappelle
j'avais et les gars qui faisait leur
leur cours leur leur fournitures parce
que le premier jour de classe c'est
magnifique quand il donne tout à l'heure
il faut deux cahiers petits carreaux à
intercalaire non à intercalaire j'avais
dit bah oui j'avais dit intercalaire oui
voilà
spirale passe spirale tu as raison et
donc les gars quelle est là-bas frère
c'était les taulier je peux te dire ils
avaient des cahiers frère je m'en
rappelle il y avait les claire fontaine
le stylo il décrivait tout seul
le gars qui avait à Clairefontaine elle
s'accroche pas la feuille mon frère mais
sans déconner a été comment ça glisser
la feuille c'est du patinage artistique
moi j'avais les frères sur ma vie
j'avais des feuilles tu connais des
feuilles quand tu sors d'un plastique
quand tu achètes au supermarché
et la feuille déjà même tu l'as même pas
touché elle est grise
moi je m'étais même plus de points sur
les i je t'ai dit trous tu connais la
elle est dégueulasse mon frère tu as
l'impression frère qui était déjà tu
sais que tu vas avoir une mauvaise note
d'ailleurs le prof il a même pas envie
d'avoir sa feuille recyclé en fait c'est
horrible non mais il y avait les gars
qui avaient les claire fontaine frère je
me rappelle et quand tu demandais aussi
un gars une feuille double
Clairefontaine frère déjà le gars il y
avait 2 / 20
tu as pas une feuille
[Rires]
c'est la dernière fois
sans déconner il te donner la feuille
mon frère mais il était en Shrek et son
contrôle
et il y avait les feuilles je te dis
dans un papier plastique frère tu avais
1000 feuilles pour toute l'année
mais moi je faisais tout avec quoi par
exemple bah quand il y avait pas de
papier toilette
[Applaudissements]
mais pour les jeter sur les gens à côté
plus côté
l'odeur de la colle mais je rappelle
tout l'odeur de ton cul
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention
à l'école c'était incroyable moi je me
rappelle pour alors il faut pas le faire
mais pour éviter les contrôles quand je
savais vraiment pas fait un contrôle du
tout fallait mettre de la colle dans la
serrure dans la serrure de l'air et je
me rappelle la prof elle est
[Rires]
s'il vous plaît
ce qui se passe
[Rires]
on va trouver une autre classe
impossible
[Rires]
ouais franchement tu es relou Thomas
c'est pas la première fois que tu le
fais si tu as pas pris le contrôle c'est
pas bien ouais mais ça c'était
magnifique au moins parce que ça prenait
du temps et après je disais à la prof
moi ce que moi je t'ai dit classe madame
comme le contrôle de Vinci mineur
mais le contrôle était repoussé donc ça
vous permettait de le réviser
au lendemain et le lendemain j'avais un
truc à faire
ou pas
j'avais une douleur ici comme un fuisoir
alors incroyable le premier job de ma
vie c'était en banque à la BNP
[Rires]
fromage
j'étais au service courrier vous savez
il y avait une machine incroyable qui
embête mettez sous enveloppe plein de
trucs et moi j'avais pas compris que ça
va pas mettre des il y avait des
feuilles parfois avec un chèque qui
était agrafé et on avait bien dit
surtout quand il y a un truc agrafé dont
un chèque ne met pas ça dans la machine
à envelopper comme ça faisait chier de
plier à la main c'est pas grave ça va ça
a marché et le nombre de chèques que
j'ai mis dedans qui ne sont jamais
arrivés chez les gens non
c'est déjà déjà les bonnes anecdotes
BNP pour me job j'ai même vu ça sur mon
compte retraite c'est même marqué normal
parce que c'est parce que un moment le
numéro de la banque quand tu as pas
d'oseille je peux te dire
ce qu'il fait il a pas compris qu'on a
qu'on a capté le bail il t'appelle d'un
autre poste mais les deux premiers
numéros c'est toujours les mêmes
il envoie le conseiller oui c'est
Monsieur Martinez le conseiller votre
conseiller monsieur annunesco pouvez
nous rappeler parce qu'on est à -840 €
et il y a un chèque de 28 € qui arrive
on pourra pas l'honorer
rappelez-nous plus vite merci Monsieur
et la tapé et tu disais non alors là je
suis sur un très gros bail là
[Applaudissements]
je suis sur un très très gros bail bon
je vous le dis à vous mais
à vous je vous cache pas que je vais
certainement tourné avec Steven
Spielberg
bah là j'ai fait le casting
sachez que il m'a dit qu'il allait me
recontacter mais très vite là donc je
pense qu'il faut honorer ce chèque et
parce qu'après quand ça va décoller ça
va décoller joli ah bah jolie il vaut
mieux me faire confiance maintenant
parce que je vais tout exploser je vous
le dis merci merci je vous embrasse je
passerai vous voir à la semaine
prochaine merci Madame Durieux
est-ce que vous êtes récents la même
banque d'ailleurs entre la période où
c'était compliqué et celle-là
une des banques quoi
comme tout le monde des problèmes
d'argent fort et tous les jours la
banque a pris à Monsieur vous êtes à
découvert c'est quelqu'un de très connu
et vous le connaissez et un jour il a
réussi
il était tellement traumatisé par le
banquier qu'il a fait tous les jours que
il appelait lui quand il était riche
bonjour le banquier j'ai combien sur mon
compte en banque ce matin tous les jours
il a fait pour c'est vous le connaissez
très bien c'est ouf moi j'ai fait ça
aussi un temps puis après j'ai arrêté de
le faire
plus non mais non mais les banquiers
c'est bon après ils font leur travail
mais il y en a qui font du zèle c'est
vrai qu'il te met il te mette une
horreur très tôt à 8h du matin avant
l'ouverture il faut les il faut les
débiteurs avant l'ouverture il passe en
revue je connais ça par cœur c'est ma
vie hein alors là
c'est c'est c'est
vrai
franchement
je ne répond pas
55 c'est que des mauvaises nouvelles tu
as déjà entendu un gars à 7h55 il
t'appelle pour donner de l'oseille faire
c'est ou un gars qui veut te demander de
l'oseille ou un gars qui tu dois
l'oseille à 7h55
j'ai fait plein de petits boulots
c'est assistante de photographe et j'ai
travaillé dans une salle de sport je
travaille en institut de beauté j'ai
rempli des bouteilles pour avec du sirop
j'ai
travaillé dans une grande maison de
prêt-à-porter là-dessus on va s'arrêter
sur les bouteilles avec le sirop
c'est quoi ce métier
exactement j'étais au poste remplissage
de sirop dans les bouteilles les
Pyrénées ouais grave
non il y avait des endroits où on
servait des bouteilles d'eau avec des
des sirops et puis bah alors ce qu'il
faut faire c'est ouvrir la bouteille
d'eau la personne nous fait confiance et
on l'ouvre en amont on vide un peu d'eau
généralement on est au allez je dirais
un huitième
c'est quoi le cursus
tu mets un peu de sirop c'est vrai que
tu fais un kiffe parce que moi je
mettais du sirop de pêche c'était
extraordinaire parce que la pêche c'est
comme ma peau
vous avez une peau de pêche pot de pêche
j'ai une peau de pêche tu peux y aller
vas-y fais-toi plaisir
[Applaudissements]
elle est sensuelle elle fait comme un
fait
15 fois par jour
ok la nuit avant de me coucher
fais le plus bravo en tout cas vous avez
tous des métiers incroyable c'est quoi
votre premier boulot toi je n'ai pas
peur des poules donc on m'employait pour
les temps
donc en employé pour des travaux
agricoles comme la moitié de femmes de
ma famille sont des agriculteurs et donc
je ramassais les œufs dans le poulailler
et c'est pas si simple que ça parce que
c'était évidemment de la nourriture par
grain et tout ça mais vous pouvez avoir
des milliers de poules autour de vous si
vous avez peur vous susciter une panique
dans le poulailler donc ça marchait bien
j'ai vu ce film panique dans le poulet
je peux tenir que tu te chies dessus
une attaque de poules et tout panique
dans le poulailler et après j'ai ramassé
les pommes de terre avec j'étais très
bon sur la machine j'étais un des plus
doués il faut aller très vite parce que
sinon vous laissez passer les cailloux
dans les sacs de pommes de terre c'est
pas possible c'est dingue parce que en
fait tu vois tout le monde c'était sympa
et toi tu nous a déjà
passé
sinon tu as fait quoi d'autre parce que
animateur de centre de loisirs à toi
[Rires]
les enfants venez
manger les enfants là j'ai mal à ma
France Tibo
quel âge c'était quel âge
garçon fille et bien une très bonne
première année et on met les a retiré à
la deuxième
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable alors moi c'est à Royan
[Rires]
elle chassait le mammouth
les enfants au Guignols Guérin c'est
d'ailleurs je leur dis bonjour c'est les
170 ans du guignol et je faisais rentrer
aussi au manège et je faisais vous savez
je faisais l'animation au micro allez
allez rouler les petits bolides
et on s'accroche on tire à la queue du
Mickey pour avoir un tour gratuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'adore ramener des trucs là tu vas
gagner des trucs là
tu passes pour un héros frère tu as
l'impression moi j'arrive et moi je
tirais à la carabine bam mon fils est
arrivé sans déconner une proie pour
c'était incroyable prenez pour clintils
je te le dis moi mon frère mais mon fils
moi en fait je faisais toutes les
attractions quand on était au truc je
ramenais pratiquement tous les j'ai
ramené une boutique de peluche frère sur
ma vie dans la voiture on mettait tout
dans le coffre on était comme des ouf et
on gagnait des peluches on rigolait et
on était comme des ouf quand tu gagnais
un petit pistolet à eau mais tu jouais
toute la journée avec après
vous prendre au tir hein parce que je
suis hyper bonne au tire ah non mais
imbattable de faire l'inverse j'ai je
sais pas j'ai un œil
[Rires]
très tôt le tocard de la patate
[Applaudissements]
on te jugera pas non mais parce que là
je te sens un peu
vas-y mais t'en sers très tôt après
j'avais arrêté pendant 3-4 mois j'avais
été travaillé au petit frère des pauvres
c'est pour aider les petits vieux
tu vas livrer pour eux mais après c'est
juste bénévole
tu sais qu'on t'a pas demandé une
interview
1 2 et le troisième que j'avais kiffé
comme petit boulot j'avais travaillé
pour une société médicament ça ouais et
il y en aura assez un costard un costard
et une Clio moi j'étais content
je t'avais dit il y en a des bons
métiers mieux que manutentionnaire et en
fait je venais juste des enveloppes je
portais des enveloppes j'étais ah non tu
étais genre tu étais pas genre
présentant pour les médicaments même pas
j'ai amené une lettre à un cabinet un
autre cabinet dans des sociétés en fait
je savais pas ce que tu fais en fait
donner une lettre pour dire qu'il y
avait un nouveau médicament et après il
t'appelais pour prendre un rendez-vous
exact et sauf que ton chien m'a appelé
si on veut ta tronche
et après je suis retourné dans la
livraison et j'ai pu bouger depuis 29
ans dans la livraison voilà c'est bon je
sais pas si c'est beau ça c'est beau par
contre la récré là c'est marrant hein
bonsoir bonsoir mannequin alors là
d'abord des petits boulots à partir de
16 17 ans pour gagner de l'argent de
poche tu as fait quoi comme études toi
moi j'ai fait une prépa je sais maxer
prépa HEC une école de commerce
parce que moi aussi j'ai fait plein de
préparation j'ai fait une préparation H
encore hier
au cinéma pour tendre absolument par
contre après tu as le cul qui gratte
donc ouais j'ai fait j'ai donné des
cours de tennis à une vieille dame qui
était très gentille ça me faisait un peu
d'argent du baby-sitting des cours de
cours de maths aussi à des élèves qui
étaient nuls et moi j'étais pas non plus
très bonne mais ça suffisait et après à
partir de 18 ans j'ai fait des photos
pour payer mes études voilà mais si ça
vous intéresse pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
elle me met monteur tu avais des belles
feuilles à l'école et voilà toujours un
dénigrer
parce que vous vous travaillez à la
cuisine
après peut-être parce que vous étiez un
besoin mieux vous travaillez beaucoup
vous gagnez beaucoup vous voyez non ou
alors vous étiez crados tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai retrouvé l'autre jour dans les
papiers parce que j'avais fait un
emprunt pour m'acheter mon premier
ordinateur portable quand j'ai fait mon
école de commerce il coûtait 15000
francs à l'époque très très longtemps
15000 francs c'était un Toshiba un PC tu
vois et j'avais fait un emprunt à la
banque et le taux d'intérêt était de 14
%. bonjour c'est vrai il va revenir nous
voir actuellement il a été pris chez
Toshiba
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et donc c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé
avec mannequin
pour payer tes études exactement c'est
la seule qui pourrait le faire
aussi ah oui Valérie oui bien sûr
Valérie elle était à la maison
elle est avec moi
je pense qu'il a une Binche aussi
[Rires]
je te cache pas qu'on a du mal à y
croire
dis-moi bah non mais j'aurais très bien
pu défiler je vous rappelle que à Mister
camping sauvage j'ai fait trois fois
deux heures
ah bah voilà
bien sûr on était trois candidats j'ai
terminé deuxième
sur 3 c'est le ventre voilà donc voilà
c'est pas loin d'être ridicule mais tu
es loin d'être ridicule solide oui je te
le dis oui moi j'ai travaillé au McDo à
Oberhausbergen 13 Strasbourg et je
m'occuper des boissons fraîches et des
glaces et un jour je me suis fait
convoquer parce qu'il y avait une
disparition suspecte de caramel
c'est pour ça que le matin quand
j'arrive à 7h je me versais où il y a la
machine comme ça je vous mettais plein
de caramel dans le truc et je mangeais
comme ça
jusqu'au haut du M là vous voyez le même
sur les Sunday elle est jusqu'au haut du
M et j'ai défoncé le Sunday comme ça
en fait il y a que des des personnes
c'est une émission de cassos